welcome to the Future Academy where we
teach you the fundamentals to become a
better designer storyteller and creator
hi i'm krista the founder and CEO of the
future I've been running the design
studio blind for over 24 years and have
been an educator for the past 15 my
mission is to educate the masses and
teach creatives to know their value and
try to be valuable to others we're
creating a second channel because
believe it or not we have too much
content to share with you and don't want
to bombard your channel with too much
stuff that you're not looking for on our
main channel we focus on teaching
creative entrepreneurs about business
money and mindset that's why we decided
to make this second channel the future
Academy here we'll focus on teaching you
the fundamentals in the most dynamic and
fun way possible through exercises demos
and breakdowns so you can learn the
software and skills needed to become a
professional creative show my hope in
creating a second channel like the
future Academy is to be able to give you
guys more of what it is you're looking
for to do the deeper dives but also to
diversify the content into editing
cinematography of motion graphics and
animation other kinds of skills may be
hem lettering things that you're
interested in you'll be seeing some
seasoned vets here like Matthew Big Ben
and Greg have been practicing their
craft for well over a decade they'll be
sharing their expertise and experiences
from the industry we'll also be bringing
on some fresh faces to share their
knowledge so you can grow and have the
most relevant education possible so
whether you want to learn typography
layouts color science or editing we're
here to help you grow and succeed so we
can see you in the future
[Music]